Here's what statistician do. They choose a random sample.
The sample is the selection of hopefully random withdrawn people from this pool
that are representative of the pool at large.
In this sample, they might derive an estimate on how people are likely to vote.
They might just report that as estimate,
but in practice, what they do is they report that the estimate plus a margin of error.
In this margin of error, means what's really been given back is not singular number like 60%,
but an interval--we call this the confidence interval.
Look at these numbers for the blue party or party A and tell me
what do you think is the lower bound and upper bound in the conference interval in percent.